TEAM AND THE MEDIA GOES
BERSERK.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
NOW, IF YOU HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING AMERICAN POLITICS
OVER THE LAST NINE MONTHS OR
SO AND YOU HAVE A DECENTLY
FUNCTIONING HUMAN BRAIN, YOU
SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
SURPRISED TO WAKE UP TO THE
NEWS THAT REX TILLERSON IS
OUT AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> REX AND I HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR A
LONG TIME.
WE GOT A LONG ACTUALLY QUITE
WELL.
BUT WE DISAGREED ON THINGS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE IRAN
DEAL, I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
I GUESS HE THOUGHT IT WAS
OKAY.
I WANTED TO EITHER BREAK IT
OR DO SOMETHING AND HE FELT
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY.
SO WE WERE NOT REALLY
THINKING THE SAME.
>> Laura: TILLERSON, WHO WAS
TOLD HE WAS BEING LET GO ON
FRIDAY BY GENERAL KELLY,
SPOKE BRIEFLY TO REPORTERS
TODAY.
AND HE DIDN'T LOOK WELL.
HE WAS VISIBLY EMOTIONAL.
>> I WANT TO SPEAK NOW TO MY
STATE DEPARTMENT COLLEAGUES
AND TO OUR INTERAGENCY
COLLEAGUES AND PARTNERS AT
DOD AND THE JOINT CHIEF OF
STAFFS MOST PARTICULARLY.
TO MY FOREIGN SERVICE
OFFICERS AND CIVIL SERVICE
COLLEAGUES, WE ALL TOOK THE
SAME OATH OF OFFICE WHETHER
YOU ARE CAREER EMPLOYEE OR
POLITICAL APPOINTEE, WE ARE
ALL BOUND BY THAT COMMON
COMMITMENT.
>> Laura: THAT WAS NICE.
WELL, BACK IN NOVEMBER, I
ASKED THE PRESIDENT ABOUT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S JOB
SECURITY.
>> I WANT MY -- MY VISION IS
MY VISION ANYWAY.
IT'S CALLED COST-SAVING.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
COST-SAVING.
REX IS IN THERE WORKING
HARD.
HE IS DOING HIS BEST.
>> Laura: IS HE GOING TO BE
WITH YOU FOR THE DURATION?
>> WE'LL SEE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IS GOING TO
BE.
>> Laura: WELL, NOT EXACTLY
A RINGING ENDORSEMENT OF THE
DURATION.
WELL, THE OF COURSE, THE
LEMMINGS IN THE PRESS SPENT
THE ENTIRE DAY PAINTING THE
TILLERSON FIRING AS EVIDENCE
OF MORE WHITE HOUSE
DYSFUNCTION.
>> THIS ALMOST FEELS LIKE A
VACATION FROM THE REALITY TV
STYLE TURMOIL THAT IS
TURNING BACK IN WASHINGTON.
THE PRESIDENT MAY BE
WONDERING WHY HE DIDN'T COME
TO CALIFORNIA SOONER.
THIS IS HIS FIRST TRIP OUT
HERE BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING
THAT HE HAS LEFT BEHIND.
>> WHAT DOES CHAOS MEAN IN
OUR FOREIGN POLICY?
IT MEANS MANY OF OUR ALLIES
WHO I HAVE WORKED FOR OVER
THE YEARS, THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT NEXT FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT CREATES A VACUUM IN THE
WORLD THAT RUSSIA IS MOVING
INTO VERY QUICKLY AND CHINA
IS MOVING IN TO IN ASIA.
>> Laura: OH, YEAH.
TRUMP CAUSED THE RISE OF
CHINA AND THE RUSSIA
AGGRESSION IN CRIMEA.
OH MY GOODNESS.
CHAOS.
YOU MEAN WHAT WE SAW FOR THE
EIGHT YEARS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHEN BARACK
OBAMA DIDN'T FIRE ANYONE
OVER BENGHAZI, THE IRS
TARGETING OF CONSERVATIVES,
OR THE FAST AND FURIOUS
SCANDAL?
OR WAS IT THE CHAOS WE SAW
WHEN OBAMA PUSHED OUT
QADDAFI AND MUBARAK SPARKING
THE RISE OF ISIS IN IRAQ AND
IN SYRIA?
NOW, WHAT ABOUT THE CHAOS OF
DOUBLING OUR DEBT AND
EXPLODING THE TRADE DEFICIT.
IS CHINA,.
>> , GREW BOLDER AND MORE
POWERFUL, DID ANY OF THAT
COUNT AS CHAOS?
WELL, TRUMP, BY CONTRAST,
HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT WE
WANT TO HAVE BETTER
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MORE
NATIONS, IF POSSIBLE.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ANYONE'S PUSHOVER.
LOOK, THE FACT IS TILLERSON
SHOULD HAVE TENDERED HIS
RESIGNATION A LONG TIME AGO.
HE DISAGREED WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON MAJOR ISSUES.
WITH THE NORTH KOREA.
HE SUPPORTED THE PARIS
CLIMATE ACCORDS.
HE QUESTIONED THE
PRESIDENT'S CHARLESVILLE
RESPONSE.
HE WAS AT ODDS AT MOVING THE
U.S. EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM
AND WAS A FAN OF THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT, OF COURSE,
WALLS NOT A FAN.
OTHER THAN THAT, THE TWO
WERE PERFECTLY INSYNC.
>> CAN YOU ADDRESS THE MAIN
HEADLINE OF THIS STORY DID
YOU CALL THE PRESIDENT A
MORON AND WHERE DO YOU THINK
THE REPORTS.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO DEAL
WITH PETTY STUFF LIKE THAT.
THIS IS WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND ABOUT WASHINGTON.
AGAIN, I'M NOT FROM THIS
PLACE BUT THE PLACES I COME
FROM, WE DON'T DEAL WITH
THAT KIND OF PETTY NONSENSE.
>> Laura: THE PLACE I COME
FROM AS IF YOU CALL YOUR
BOSS A MORON, YOU PROBABLY
SHOULD BE IN THAT POSITION.
THE ONLY QUESTION I HAVE IS
WHY DID IT TAKE THE
PRESIDENT SO LONG TO FIRE
TILLERSON?
SURE, HE IS A NICE GUY BUT
COME ON.
CIA DIRECTOR MIKE POMPEO BY
ALL ACCOUNTS IS A FAR BETTER
FIT TO BE TRUMP'S SECRETARY
OF STATE.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID, KIND
OF ABOUT CHEMISTRY AND
APPROACH.
TILLERSON DIDN'T GEL IN
EITHER CATEGORY.
>> I HAVE GOTTEN TO KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE VERY WELL OVER
THE LAST YEAR, AND I'M
REALLY AT A POINT WHERE WE
ARE GETTING VERY CLOSE TO
HAVING THE CABINET AND OTHER
THINGS THAT I WANT.
>> Laura: AND SINCE LAST
SUMMER, THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN SLOWLY GETTING HIS TEAM
TOGETHER.
THINK ABOUT IT HE HIRED
GENERAL JOHN KELLY HIS CHIEF
OF STAFF.
HE MOVED SARAH SANDERS IN AS
PRESS SECRETARY.
HE MOVED TOM PRICE OUT AND
ALEX AZAR IN AS SECRETARY OF
HHS AND I'M SURE THERE IS
GOING TO BE A LOT MORE